Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Emma Gon
Siempre que tengo la oportunidad de convivir
con un público tan diverso como Uds. es un reto.
Es un reto emocional, primero que nada, puesto que desde mi punto de vista
yo soy "psicoloco", estudié psicología clínica.
Y el aprendizaje tiene que ser vivencial.
Si el aprendizaje sólo es racional, llega un momento que el cuerpo
tiene algo que yo le llamo, con respecto y con cariño, "hora nalga".
Y cuando la nalga se cansa, el cerebro se atonta.
Esto es real. Esto es cierto.
Esto lo estudia por ahí la psicología.
Y el día de hoy quiero pedirles un favor.
Quiero pedirles...
Es la última conferencia de esta primera mañana.
Hemos tenido extraordinarias exposiciones,
una lluvia de ideas mágicas que yo...
¡coño, estoy inspirado y ya no sé ni qué decir!
Pero el día de hoy me encantaría de verdad
que me ayudaran a hacer un ejercicio todos juntos.
Que agarraran su mano derecha y le hicieran así. (Sacude la mano)
Si me ayudan a prender las luces del teatro
para ver a los que no lo están haciendo
y señalarlos pa' que vean lo que se siente.
Muchas gracias.
Las dos manos, por favor. Las dos manos. Muy bien. Las dos manos.
Quiero que volteen a ver a la persona de al lado
y véanle hacer esto y cómo pierde toda la forma, el estatus, ¿no?
Y si todavía te sirve aún, vamos a hacer honor a un genio,
Albert Einstein, que cuando le entregan su Premio Nobel en la Física
el güey saca la lengua, ¿no?
Sácale la lengua al de al lado.
¡Sácale la lengua! No te va a pasar nada.
Y puede ser que tal vez al sacar la lengua
secretes endorfina en tu cuerpo
y mi compadre, que conoce un poquito de la risa,
sabe que la endorfina es muy buena para el organismo.
¿Cierto o falso? No te oigo.
Tengo un reto para esta última conferencia.
Quiero pedirles de favor quién vive conmigo este reto.
El resto es bien simple: todos somos iguales, ¿cierto o falso?
El concepto de TED es personas que vienen
y comparten una idea con gente igual a ellos, ¿cierto o falso?
Cualquiera de Uds. podría estar aquí en este escenario
compartiendo alguna idea si hubiese hecho toda la participación.
Yo lo creo rotundamente.
Y yo creo algo: como somos iguales, te tengo un reto.
Yo voy a estar aquí parado 18 minutos.
Quiero pedirte que vivas esta conferencia junto conmigo
puesto de pie y vas a ver que va a ser una revolución.
¿Me ayuda o no me ayuda?
Todo el mundo póngase de pie, ¡venga!
Es bien fácil. Es bien simple.
No va a pasar absolutamente nada.
Tu cuerpo se va a cargar de energía
y vas a disfrutar esta conferencia mucho mejor.
Me dieron el controlcito.
Y esta conferencia se llama "Es posible lo imposible".
¡Ayúdenme! ¿Cómo se llama?
Audiencia: Es posible lo imposible.
Y vamos a utilizar un elemento.
Un elemento inconsciente.
-- Oye Omar, ¿qué es el inconsciente?
A mí me toca hablarte un poquito de él
porque es el sujeto en el que aprendemos.
Uds. están aquí sentados y el inconsciente
se está diciendo: "la silla está incómoda,
ya me dio comezón güey ¿qué estoy haciendo?
Tengo esto, tengo lo otro,
tengo hambre en la tripa ¡prrruuff!"
Y, [de] todo eso que pasa, tu inconsciente te genera información.
Sólo el 10% de todo lo que haces es consciente.
Y el 90% es inconsciente.
-- Oye Omar, esto ya lo sabía.
¡Es primaria uno!
Estoy totalmente de acuerdo.
Pero, saberlo y no aplicarlo, ¡es la peor de las ignorancias!
Saberlo y no aplicarlo es la peor de las ignorancias.
El inconsciente controla el 90% de ti. El 90%.
Tú vas en el carro, güey, y ves un letrero
y se te mete una marca y ni cuenta te das.
Entró por tu inconsciente.
Llegas a un restaurante, tienes hambre y el mesero te dice:
"¿Le ofrezco el especial del día? Tenemos huevitos, frijolitos"...
-- ¡Ándele, el especial del día!
El inconsciente se enganchó con la información del mesero
y tú querías una hamburguesa.
(Risas) ¿Me estoy explicando o no?
El inconsciente es una herramienta de nuestro cerebro, muy poderosa.
El día de hoy vamos a aprender cómo accesar a él.
Porque si le llegas al inconsciente, yo no sé cuáles sean sus proyectos,
por eso es difícil un público de TED.
Porque hay un público tan diverso que no sé cuál sea tu proyecto.
¿Quieres incrementar tu negocio? ¿Tienes empleados?
¡Tienes que saber programar su inconsciente!
Te toca estar en una conferencia y te toca hablarle al público.
¡Tienes que saber hablarle al inconsciente!
¿Tienes una novia?
Tienes que saber hablarle al inconsciente: "hazme el amor".
Tienes que saber hablarle al inconsciente.
¿Me estoy explicando?
El inconsciente es una parte del cerebro que poca gente estudia.
Pero fíjate la magia de la conciencia.
Respira profundo. Exhala. Consciente.
Inconsciente, ponle atención a lo que quieras
y el cuerpo sigue trabajando solo. ¿Cierto o falso?
¿Cuántos de Uds. estuvieron sentados y le dijeron al güey de al lado...
Oye, perdónenme que diga güey pero así le hablo yo a mis amigos.
Y, de alguna manera así como Freud -padre de la psicología-
dice que la única manera de accesar al inconsciente
es con palabras altisonantes...
¿por qué quería que te sintieras mucho más cómodo?
Porque vamos a entrar al tema de esta conferencia.
Yo me hice una pregunta: ¿qué hace genios a los genios?
¿Qué hace genio a un genio?
Porque construimos mitos de ellos, ¿no?
"Las flatulencias de los genios no huelen". (Risas)
Construimos mitos, ¿no?
"Bill Gates, cuando nació, en vez de darle una nalgada
le dieron con un teclado ¡ándele, ándele!"
Construimos mitos. Y estos mitos nos desasocian de esas personas
y me hacen creer que yo soy un simple mortal y no soy un genio.
Pero, ¿sabes qué? Yo creo que todos los genios,
desde el punto de vista psicológico, somos exactamente iguales.
Yo creo que todos los seres humanos somos exactamente iguales.
Los genios también.
Químicamente están hechos del mismo CHON:
Carbón, Hidrógeno, Oxígeno y Nitrógeno. ¿Cierto o falso?
O el chon que papá y mamá se quitaron para pasar el proceso de creación.
Pero es exactamente el mismo.
-- Omar, si químicamente estamos todos hechos de lo mismo,
¿por qué somos todos tan distintos?
¿Buena pregunta o mala pregunta?
Porque si químicamente todos estamos hechos de lo mismo,
el cerebro de todos funciona igual,
el inconsciente de todos funciona igual,
las emociones de todos funcionan igual,
¿por qué somos tan diferentes?
¿Buena pregunta o mala pregunta?
Entonces, yo vi la película Quién quiere ser millonario
(Who wants to be a millionaire)
y la película presenta un argumento extraordinario.
Cuatro partes: Suerte, Inteligencia, Dones o Destino.
Y yo dije, yo voy a copiarme esos argumentos para mi ponencia en TED.
¿Por qué los genios son genios? ¿Será por suerte?
Déjame y te digo algo: la probabilidad de que
te saques la lotería es una de 30 millones.
Si no compras el boleto, güey, nunca te la vas a sacar.
Si lo compras, tienes la misma posibilidad que cualquiera. ¿Sí o no?
No te oigo. ¿Sí o no?
Va. Ponme atención.
La probabilidad de que tú estuvieras vivo era una de 300 millones.
Porque tú le partiste la mandarina a 300 millones de espermatozoides
que estaban guardados en la vesícula seminal de tu padre
cuando tu papá y tu mamá estaban haciendo cuchi-cuchi,
tú estabas ahí en la vesícula seminal diciendo:
"le voy a ganar, le voy a ganar, le voy a ganar"
¿Y sabes qué pasó?
Le partiste la mandarina, médicamente, a 300 millones de espermatozoides.
Por lo tanto, la probabilidad de estar vivo es una de 300 millones.
Ya que estás vivo, güey, todos tenemos la misma suerte.
¿Me estoy explicando o no?
Porque estarás de acuerdo conmigo que alguien
que se saca la Lotería Nacional, una de 30 millones,
es un güey muy suertudo. ¿Sí o no?
Alguien que está vivo, güey, ¡es muy suertudo!
Una de 300 millones.
Y si a eso le sumamos las posibilidades de todas las veces
que su papá se echó alguna canita al aire,
imagínate nomás todas las demás posibilidades
que hubiéramos tenido de nacer.
¿Sí me expliqué? Es broma, pero en esta sociedad
también es cierto, como psicólogo [lo digo].
-- No es suerte Omar. La gente no es genio por suerte. Es por inteligencia.
Albert Einstein a los siete años fue diagnosticado
[de] lento de aprendizaje. ¿Cierto?
Salvador Dalí hasta los nueve años no había dado ningún brote de nada.
Pero un día, igual que al papá de Gaby Vargas,
llega la mamá de Dalí y le dice:
"Hijo, ¡pintas como sólo los dioses lo saben hacer!" (Risas)
Imagínate, güey, que tú le llevas un dibujo
de primero de primaria a tu mamá, ¿no?
Le llevas el dibujo y tu mamá lo agarra y tu mamá…
la mamá de Salvador Dalí era medio lurias, ¿no?
Y agarra a Dalí y le dice: "¡pintas como sólo los dioses lo saben hacer!"
Le da un abrazo y le da un beso.
Salvador Dalí se creyó dios y creó el surrealismo.
Una manera personal e individual de ver el mundo.
Lo entrevistan en los EE.UU. cuando iba a exponer
en el Museo de Arte Moderno de Nueva York.
El primer pintor que expone en el Museo de Arte Moderno de Nueva York.
Llevaba el avión con todos sus cuadros, güey.
Y llega Salvador Dalí a EE.UU. y el agente de la Aduana le dice:
"Maestro, ¿algo de valor que traiga desde España?"
Y Dalí se le queda viendo y dice:
"Je. ¡Todo lo que ve!" (señalándose a sí mismo).
(Aplausos)
-- Oye Omar, no es suerte. No es inteligencia.
Albert Einstein fue diagnosticado lento de aprendizaje
exactamente igual que muchos otros niños, ¿pero qué tuvo?
Tuvo un papá brillante que le regaló una brújula
y le despertó el pensamiento creativo.
Y Albert Einstein andaba preguntando, ¿por qué la brújula apunta hacia el norte?
¿por qué la brújula apunta hacia el norte?
Alguien le dijo: "la brújula apunta hacia el norte porque así lo quiso Dios".
El güey dijo: "¿Y quién es Dios?"
-- "El creador de todo el universo".
-- "¿Y qué es el universo?"
-- "Pues, todo lo que existe".
Albert Einstein dice: "¿Y qué es lo chido? ¿Quién es el chido aquí?"
-- "Pues, ¡Dios!"
Y su siguiente pregunta, y la misma con la que murió y no me crean a mí.
A mí no me crean nada.
Métanse en YouTube e investiguen todo lo que digo.
(Risas)
Busquen en YouTube: "últimas entrevistas a Albert Einstein".
Y está Albert Einstein, güey.
Y lo están entrevistando en Berkley y le preguntan
que si tiene alguna respuesta que todavía
le haya quedado duda y el güey pregunta,
y el güey dice: "Desde que tengo siete años,
todavía me sigo preguntando cuáles serán los pensamientos de Dios".
Un niño de siete años diagnosticado lento de aprendizaje
se metió una idea: ver el mundo como si fuera Dios.
Dios ve el universo distinto a ti y a mí, ¿cierto o falso?
Los átomos distinto a ti y a mí, ¿cierto o falso?
Y los vio desde una perspectiva distinta y logró ser
uno de los hombres más geniales en la historia de la humanidad.
¿Pero sabes qué me encanta?
Que algunas anécdotas de alumnos de él cuentan
que el güey daba clases y que de repente estaban todos los alumnos.
Y que de repente él se escondía detrás de la puerta y salía, "¡Aaaggrrr!"
El hombre más brillante de la historia de la humanidad
tenía una mirada de niño.
Sacaba la lengua cuando le tomaban fotos
y en las clases era extremadamente informal.
¿De qué me habla eso?
Que desarrollar este niño que tenemos dentro
es una manera también de desarrollar
nuestra creatividad y nuestra genialidad.
Hablaban de la autoestima: "ten autoestima".
Pero, ¿cómo le hago para tener autoestima?
El maestro de la autoestima es Salvador Dalí.
El hombre más narciso del mundo, el que se amaba a sí mismo.
Y, ¿sabes qué hacía? Hablaba con él mismo en voz alta.
Alguien se le acercaba: "Dalí, ¿quieres comer?"
-- "Un segundo. Maestro Dalí, ¿Ud. quiere comer?"
Es neta, esto es neta. Y Dalí decía:
"Mmm, ahora todavía no tener hambre".
-- "El Maestro Dalí no tener hambre".
Desarrolló una doble personalidad.
Se comunicaba con su alter ego y él solamente hablaba con Dalí,
pero hablaba con él en voz alta.
Sinónimo de la locura. ¿Pero qué descubrí?
Albert Einstein daba clases, güey, en bicicleta en voz alta.
Y hablaba para él. ¿Qué descubrí?
Jesús hablaba en voz alta. Siddhartha Gautama hablaba en voz alta.
Todos los grandes genios que estudié hablaban en voz alta.
Y a nosotros nos dijeron que eso era de locos.
Tu cerebro funciona de la siguiente manera:
tu cerebro sigue indicaciones.
Primera característica del inconsciente.
Ponme atención. El cerebro humano sigue indicaciones.
-- Oye Omar, ¿indicaciones de quién?
¡De todo el mundo! Ese es el problema del cerebro, güey.
Que cualquier persona que le diga algo, se la cree.
La mujer va caminando.
Se levantó, se puso sus medias, está bien guapa.
Se perfumó, se habló en el espejo.
Dijo: "¡Qué guapa estoy! Cabrón, mira macho, ¡mua!"
Y va saliendo, caminando en la calle
y alguien taxista le grita: "¡Quítate, gorda!" (Risas)
Esa mujer todo el día ya valió madre, el pantalón le aprieta.
¿Por qué me comí la hamburguesa?
No debí de haber comido torta de tamal en la mañana.
¿Sí o no? ¿Sí o no?
¿Y sabes qué es lo más extraordinario, güey?
No era para ella.
Era para una gorda que estaba más adelante. (Risas)
Pero su cerebro, como no discrimina, sigue indicaciones.
Y le mete, "soy gorda".
Y le habla de su trauma porque nadie le enseñó el modelo de los genios.
Si alguien le hubiera enseñado el método de los genios
y le dicen en este instante: "Gorda".
Y ella dice: "Me hubieras visto hace un mes.
Estaba más, pero nunca vas a tener mis carnes".
Y continúa caminando… (Risas)
¿Qué hicieron la mayoría de los genios
para lograr despertar en ellos una creatividad?
Michael Jordan, un genio para encestar canastas.
El güey practicaba 2000 tiros diarios, todos los días.
2000 tiros diarios, todos los días.
¿Era un genio? No, era un güey obsesivo.
(Risas) ¿Sí me expliqué?
Tiger Woods. Factura 120 millones de dólares al año jugando golf.
¿Y el güey es muy bueno para jugar golf?
Sí, pero una vez que gana, se regresa.
Espera que todos se vayan y regresa un mes después
al campo y vuelve a jugar el campo para perfeccionar.
-- Oye, güey, ¡pero ya ganó!
Pero quiere perfeccionar su técnica.
La genialidad es igual a la repetición.
Además, el cerebro es programable, güey.
Tú al cerebro le dices algo y el cerebro se programa.
Ojo, gran secreto de la psicología: el cerebro no sigue órdenes.
No sigue, ¿qué?
Órdenes. Las órdenes las rechazamos.
Papá y mamá nos tienen hasta la madre con órdenes.
¡Ya las rechazamos!
Pero, ¿qué hacemos cuando alguien te da una indicación?
Ejemplo: "Tú, para acá, inmediatamente
ven a darme un beso cabrona".
Nadie viene. Misma frase, misma sintaxis:
"Tú, para acá, inmediatamente ven a darme un beso cabrona".
(Risas)
Hubo alguna que otra risa de "Sí, ¿iré?"
(Risas) ¿Sí me estoy explicando?
Lo único que hice fue cambiar el tono de voz.
Al cambiar el tono de voz la frase entra derechito al cerebro.
Ten mucho cuidado cómo le hablas a tus hijos.
Porque si todos los días le dices:
"eres un tonto, eres un bueno para nada, no sirves para esto",
el cerebro se programa y hace hábitos.
Así de simple. Ten mucho cuidado en lo que le cuentas.
Ten mucho cuidado en lo que le comunicas a tu mujer.
-- ¿A dónde vas?
-- ¡Ay de ti que llegues borracho!
Y, ¿sabes cómo va a llegar?
Pero déjame y te digo algo: el cerebro humano tiene una capacidad.
La capacidad de interpretar.
Cuando yo tenía seis años de edad, mi mamá me llevaba a la primaria.
Iba tarde, se le metió un carro y mi mamá
le pitó "ta-ta-ta-tata" y le tiró el dedo.
Estaba enojada con mi papá una noche antes.
Y yo le pregunto a los seis años:
"Mamá, ¿qué es esto mamá?" (gesto)
Mi mamá se impresionó como la ley del karma es impresionante
y se regresa inmediatamente, ¿no?
"¿Qué es esto mamá?" (gesto)
Y mi mamá se me queda viendo.
Y mi mamá era muy creativa, era muy jovial y me dice:
"Ay, mi hijito, esto es un avión. Si no sabe manejar el güey...
...pues que vuele, mira" (gesto) (Risas)
Y yo llegué con una interpretación.
Para mí, ¿esto qué es? (gesto)
Un avión.
Y mi cerebro asoció mediante huellas mnémicas,
porque así funciona el cerebro, la primera información
que recibe lo crea como una realidad.
Por eso la gente piensa que el cielo es azul, que Dios es hombre, etc., etc.
Porque lo primero que te dicen es una realidad total para ti.
El cerebro mío dijo esto es un avión. (gesto)
Yo llegué al salón de clases y el maestro Panchito preguntó:
"¿Algo nuevo que hayan aprendido con sus papás hoy niños?"
Yo levanté la mano y le dije:
"Maestro, ¿qué es esto maestro?" (mano abierta)
El maestro se me quedó viendo y me dijo: "Una mano Omar".
Y le digo, no, es un avión. Un Transformer.
¡Mire! (gesto) (Risas)
La broma pasó a mayores y se los hicieron
alumnos de segundo, de tercero, de cuarto.
Me corrieron del colegio.
Mandaron llamar a mi madre.
Y pasó un acontecimiento interesante.
Desde muy chiquito yo descubrí algo:
las cosas no significan lo mismo para mí que para los demás.
¿Y por qué te estoy diciendo esto?
Tercera característica del cerebro.
La primera: sigue indicaciones.
La segunda: el cerebro interpreta.
Y la interpretación es tu regalo, güey. Es tuya.
Tú interpretas lo que quieres. Es tu regalo.
Si alguien te ofende, tú puedes interpretar lo contrario
y sentirlo como piropo.
Y no pasa nada. Eso hacían los genios.
¿Qué crees que pensaban de Thomas Alva Edison
cuando estaba inventando el foco?
Yo sé que es un mito que se equivocó 5000 veces.
Pero imagínate que se haya equivocado 500 el güey.
¿Qué crees que los amigos de él pensaban?
"Oye güey, ¡ya!, deja el pinche foco, güey.
¡Ya!, ya estás traumado con el foco.
Es lo único en lo que piensas, ¡ya! Olvídate del foco.
Te has equivocado 400 veces, ¡ya!"
Pero el buey tenía algo, un valor personal. ¿Cierto o no?
Cuando su esposa lo quiso divorciar,
cuando sus hijos le dijeron: "papá estás loco".
Cuando la comunidad científica lo corrió de la comunidad científica
porque él quería inventar el foco. Lo corrieron.
Y, ¿sabes qué? Él tuvo la fuerza y el valor
y las agallas para creer en él mientras nadie creía en él.
Pareciera ser que esa es la única condición entre todos los genios.
Que tarde o temprano todo el mundo se va a poner en tu contra.
Y te van a tachar de loco en tu proyecto.
Y más si tienes proyectos nobles.
Y más si tienes proyectos... te van a tachar de loco.
La única diferencia entre los genios y la gente mediocre
es que los genios, güey, creen en ellos cuando nadie más cree en ellos.
Cuando les preguntan: "¿algo de valor que hayas traído?" Dicen...
Audiencia: "Todo lo que ves".
Primera característica: sigue indicaciones.
Segunda característica: el cerebro interpreta.
Tercera característica, esta es extraordinaria.
A la cuenta de tres vamos a hacer un ejercicio rápido.
Imagínate que estás en un supermercado.
Venga, un supermercado, un supermercado, ¿ya?
Con tu mano derecha agarra una fruta.
Una fruta, tu fruta favorita.
Agárrala. Búscala, búscala ahí a tu lado.
No agarres un melón por ahí cochino, pero agarra una fruta.
Venga, agarra una fruta. ¿Ya tienes la fruta? ¿Ya?
Quiero que a la cuenta de tres me griten el nombre de su fruta.
Uno, dos, tres. Grítenmelo.
(Respuestas)
Quiero que la huelas.
Huele tu fruta, ¿a qué huele?
Y agarra tu fruta, cierra tus ojos,
imagina que la tienes aquí y muérdela con ganas.
Venga, muérdela con ganas.
¡Ñam! Muérdela, venga. ¡Ñam!
Dale una mordida, si no lo haces no lo vives.
Dale una mordida. ¡Ñam, ñam, ñam!
Estoy seguro que automáticamente... tu boca, ¿qué hizo?
¿Tu boca qué hizo? ¿Tu boca qué hizo?
Tercera característica del cerebro:
tu mente no distingue diferencia entre realidad y fantasía.
Este es el porqué los milagros existen, güey.
No los milagros de tenía cáncer...
No los milagros de andaba en una silla y se paró.
No, no, no, no.
No, ¡milagros de neta!
Milagros. Una mujer que el marido la golpeaba todos los días.
Y un día dijo: "¡Ya no más!"
Y se levantó y lo dejó, hizo su vida y sacó adelante como pudo a su familia.
Son milagros, pero ¿en dónde existe
este poder para hacer milagros en los seres humanos?
Los genios entendían esta cualidad.
El cerebro no entiende diferencia entre realidad y fantasía.
No la entiende.
Tú te imaginaste una fruta y el cerebro secretó saliva, güey.
Y te pregunté a qué huele y me dijiste: "a mi fruta".
Y te huele a mano cochina.
(Risas) ¿Sí me expliqué?
Y tu cerebro cambió la condicionante del olor y te dio un olor de una fruta.
Engaña a tu cerebro para hacer lo que quieres.
Engáñalo. Todo el mundo lo engaña.
Lo engaña la televisión.
Lo engaña la mercadotecnia.
Lo engaña la historia.
Lo engaña tu padre y tu madre.
Güey, ¡engáñalo tú!
(Risas)
(Aplausos)